when I'm struggling to find gratitude in
my life one of the most powerful
perspectives I've used to immediately
feel it is that I imagine everything I'm
doing whether it's washing dishes
whether it's vacuuming the floor whether
it's saying goodbye to my wife whatever
the thing is I imagine it's the last
time Emma we're gonna do it and what's
crazy is that there are lots of things
that as we get older we never know the
last time we'll do something I can't
tell you the last time I had a sleepover
but if I knew when I was 11 years old
that this was the last sleepover I was
ever going to have I would have been
more grateful for it and so if you can
look at that lens knowing that like
there are some things that for the rest
of your life you're never going to do it
again it makes me appreciate the moment
more